LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE
SITTING SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER. WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON THE AGENDA. IT IS ON OUR
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR. IT IS
H.R. 16. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE.
SUNSCREEN. INGREDIENTS AND
FILTERS. LET'S TAKE A LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SENATOR
ROTH, I HEAR ROTH HERE. WHEN?
HERE. WHEN? HERE. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HERE. GONZALEZ. HERE.
GROVE. GROVE. HERE. HURTADO
LIMÓN. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. HERE.
RUBIO. PRESENT. RUBIO. PRESENT.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WIENER.
PRESENT. WIENER PRESENT. OKAY.
WITH RESPECT TO THE AGR 16 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LOWE, IS THERE
A MOTION? SO MOVED. MOVED BY
SENATOR MENJIVAR. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OKAY SENATOR ROTH.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. WHEN I WHEN I.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. I JUST NEVER THOUGHT OF
THAT. GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. YEAH.
LIMON. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WIENER AYE. WIENER. AYE.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE HAVE THIS ONE BILL ON
CONSENT. I'M HOLDING THE ROLL
OPEN, SO PLEASE VISIT US IN THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOM, ROOM 1200, ASAP. THANKS.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL ON AGR 16.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLAZER
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. CURRENT VOTE IS NINE
ZERO. WE'LL HOLD THE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBER. THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU GOT TO. LET'S OPEN
THE ROLL ON AGR 16 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. SENATOR GLAZER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS OKAY. THE VOTE
IS NINE ZERO. AND ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION 16 IS OUT. THAT
CONCLUDES THE HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH FOR
TODAY. WE ARE ADJOURNED.